all right I think we'll start so welcome
to this talk about kubernetes security
with Sto originally when I started
looking at this do I we were looking at
it for a client and it looked rather
interesting it has a lot of interesting
properties and I really wanted to sort
of dive into it and see what it could do
and the end result of this was was this
talk so I'm I'm Alan I work at Blanc I
normally work as a developer but also
with some security testing and all kinds
of other stuff in there I build
open-source security tools and I'm head
of the OS Norway chapter as well before
we we head over to Sto
we're going to discuss a little bit
about container threats so in in
kubernetes we have this thing called
pods and a pod is basically a deployment
unit and usually it's one container so
we have a pod that the pod has one
container it can have multiple
containers but the usual is is to have
one container in a pod so in this case
we have two pots we have we have a pod
with service a in it and a pod with
service B in it and we have multiple of
each these are usually deployed on notes
so they might be on the same node or
they might be on different nodes in this
case I have have them on different nodes
and then we have our not friend or enemy
the hacker that wants to hack this
solution so the hacker might try to
listen in on traffic between these nodes
or between these these pods the hacker
might try to attack one of these pots
and and gain access into the pot and if
the attacker is able to do let's say a
remote code execution attack and get
access into the pot itself and breach
that the attacker now has some more
options because maybe the attacker can
now start to attack other pots that are
not available from the outside so maybe
maybe service B was it had an open port
to the outside world but service a
didn't but now because the attacker has
been able to compromise service be the
attacker is now able to attack
service aid the attacker could also do
something else which is to try to
compromise the note so do a container
escape and become either our normal user
or the root user of the node itself and
this last threat is not something that
is do can help us a lot with but some of
the previous stuff is something is do
can help us with so it's do this is the
logo this - it's it's kind of a sailboat
and I think sto means sail in Greek so
we have this nautical team on kubernetes
with with steering wheels and everything
in it and the idea as you can see the
tagline here connect secure control and
observe services so history offers more
than just security but a lot of the
features that it offers can be used for
security as well so if you recently hit
the 1.0 milestone so this was in August
last year and the current version is one
dot zero dot five and they're fixing
small bugs they're doing all kinds of
improvements to it all the time and it's
quite an active project it's on github
and it was it's built on top of things
that have come out of Google and
especially lift which we'll get back to
but then IBM VMware and and Cisco and a
lot of other companies are also
contributing to s do it still adds to
kubernetes something we call a service
mesh and it's kind of hard to explain
what a service mesh is the only sort of
explanation I could find that made the
list some kind of sense was it's the
network of micro services and the
interactions between them because we're
kind of adding stuff that's not there at
the moment to kubernetes to to make
things better and a service mesh
typically adds things like discovery
load balancing failure recovery metrics
and monitoring which are all interesting
properties but they could also include
other things like a be testing and
canary releases so we can we can push
out a new version and just direct some
of the traffic to this new version we
can do rate limiting we can do access
control and we can do end to an
authentication this is one of the things
- this - adds
sto has some security goals
the first one is security by default and
this is a very very interesting property
because what what they aim to do is
allow you to add a certain amount of
security to the applications without
changing them so you deploy something
and then you kind of wrap it in in your
wrap around it to protect it so so you
can use it with any type of container it
doesn't have to be job or nodes or
something specific you don't even have
to have the ability to change the code
they aim to have a defense in depth so
this is going to be add-ons to existing
security things that you might have in
your network or on your hosts and they
also aim to support what we call a Sarah
trust network so if you can't trust the
network we still want to be able to
communicate between these workloads as
we color or the pods in a way where we
know that no one is listening in or
changing the traffic so we have our
trusted services once again service a
and service B and what would normally
happen is a service or a pod would speak
directly to another pod but would sto
we're going to do things a little bit
differently we're going to introduce
proxies so these proxies are in the same
pod so they're a new container in the
same pod and instead of speaking
directly between the services we now
only speak to the pot and then the pod
or oh sorry did the proxy and the proxy
speaks to the proxy at the other end and
this is how we now communicate so
there's no direct communication between
service a and service B and this is how
we can add things to this container
without actually changing the service
itself so let's look at what's going on
here
so we have what's called a sidecar
container so the proxy is a sidecar
container we also call this out of
process architecture because we're
adding new stuff without changing the
existing code we're adding a new process
that handles some of the security for us
and as I said this we this allows us to
add a lot of things without changing the
existing code so let's say this was a
database or is something that we just
purchased from someone and we want to
deploy this on a cluster
now we can actually add more security
more metrics more things to it without
changing that code which you might not
even have access to it's it's also a way
that we can do this across different
types of systems so it doesn't have to
be all Java or nodejs as I said you can
you can use this across different types
of of pods or services or containers so
what's used in initio is something
called the Envoy proxy and this was
created by lyft and it's a it's written
in C and C++ so it's really high
performance and it does a lot of things
it can do dynamic just the service
discovery it does load balancing and you
can see all the other things there so it
doesn't just do HTTP it also the this.g
RPC and we can add things like circuit
breakers we can add things like staged
rollouts with percentage based traffic's
based and this is kind of important
because you can't normally do this in
kubernetes but because you're limited to
the amount of pods you have but now you
can set a percentage I want only 1% of
this traffic to go to the new version
and then the rest should go to the old
version so you can slowly roll out the
new version we can do things like fault
injection to test the resilience of our
applications we can get richer metrics
and we can do TLS that's a part of the
proxy so but that's not all we get from
misty oh wow we have a few more things
here we have what we call the control
pain which actually controls how the
these proxy work together in there we
have something called the pilot and the
pilot is when we want to configure these
proxies we send in policies and what the
pilot will do is push those policies out
to the proxies to tell them what what
they're going to do what they're going
to allow etc etc we also have the mixer
the mixer is a thing that mainly
collects information so it collects
metrics it collects all kinds of things
around what's going on but it can also
do evaluation of things so the proxies
can ask the mixer is this thing supposed
to be allowed and then the mixer can say
yes or no
and the third part here is called
Citadel
and we'll talk a bit more about that one
later but it's the thing that helps us
with certificates and secure
communication we have a couple of more
things there we have what we call
ingress and egress so ingress is what
controls what comes into the cluster so
this is where we open up endpoints to
the outside world and we can apply these
policies all the way out during in
Indian Gress or we can apply them on the
proxies themselves and similarly we have
an egress and what was great about
having an egress here is that we can in
the egress we can control where you're
allowed to connect to and we can even
use this also if we if we have multiple
clusters where we have is to install we
can we can use these certificates that
we're going to set up we can use them
across the clusters so this one controls
how we speak to the outside world we
don't have to use it we can let the the
pod stem cells speak directly to the
outside if we want to but it can add a
lot of extra security if we can control
every every outbound communication from
any of our services so back to this
proxy the applications that we deploy
they're supposed to be unaware of this
proxies because we're going to be we are
supposed to be able to add this to our
applications without changing them and I
was wondering about this when I first
read about it like how does it actually
hijack the traffic because I mean you
could easily create your own proxy where
you would in your code you would have
just tell it to use the proxy but in
this case this just happens you just
deploy it and it suddenly starts
hijacking all the traffic and managing
it and I was kind of confused about this
at first how how can one one container
in a pod hijack the traffic of the other
container in the pod that sounds like a
problem security wise but the thing is
containers in a pod they share a network
namespace and I'm gonna show you this
what what actually happens so I have a
small human heads cluster running on my
laptop here and I have a as you can see
all the way to the top here I have this
this container called net tools and it
has two containers in it
so what I'm going to do now I'm going to
go into one of these containers up here
so it's gonna be net tools one I'm gonna
go into this one Oh remember to add
gonna get a get a shell into this
container and I'm gonna do the same
thing down here with the other one so
now I have I have a shell in two
different containers but they're in the
same pot so if I try to check here if
any is there anything listening here
there's nothing listening at all just
there's no listener zero I'm gonna set
up a listener down here so I'm gonna say
again I'm gonna listen in on local host
because that wouldn't be visible from
the outside and I'm gonna listen at a
specific port if I now go back to the
other pod and check we can see it can
see this listener because they share
local host local host is the same thing
for these two pots what's interesting
though is there's no kid here there's no
process ID and in fact if I try to do to
list all the processes I can't see this
net cap that I'm running in the in the
other container because they don't share
the process namespace they only share
the network name space so the hints they
can see one of the things but I can't
see the other they can see something is
listening but they don't know what it is
but this is also a way for two
containers to talk to each other with
within the same pod you can do this
normal doctor as well just by first
starting one container and then set the
network of the second container to be
the container Network of the first
container so something like the line I'm
showing up here so you can do the same
thing if you want to try it out you
don't have to have given Ares what's
what we're going to do when we're
deploying something with Sto is we have
this new tool normally when we're using
kubernetes we have control or a coop
couple with is do we get a new thing
called SCO
cuddle and what this one does is we can
sort of add the stuff that we want from
sto to an existing kubernetes deployment
so we we take a file that we have that
describes the deployment and we just do
this cube inject thing and it's gonna
add some new stuff to it so in this case
we see that it's added a new container
we see that it's called the proxy which
you can see down here it runs as user 1
3 3 7 with this number seems to be a
number that they use a lot leet and and
so they're adding this new container we
can also see there's something here
called a control plane policy mutual TLS
so they're adding mutual TLS that's
error and you can add all kinds of stuff
in here um but so it's adding this new
it's adding this new container it also
mounts some certificates and things down
here what it also does is it uses
something called an init container so we
talked about a sidecar container but
what's an init container well an init
container is a container that runs
before the other containers so the init
container can do things to set up the
pot itself for free the the containers
that are coming after it so uh that if
one of the differences between a normal
container and an init container is that
an inner container runs to completion
and then stops so it only runs at the
beginning and then it stops while the
other containers are running until you
kill them and in this case we also see
something all the way to the bottom here
we see that for this container we have a
special capability called net admin and
now we're kind of starting to see what's
going on here so it needs the net admin
capability and the net admin capability
allows us to redirect traffic aha
so there's something here that's going
to redirect the traffic from this
service pod and into the proxy and if we
look at the the repo or the github repo
we find that there's something called
sto iptables
I don't expect you to read all of this
by the way I'm just showing you so what
it does is it redirects traffic from all
the incoming traffic is redirected into
a certain chain and then it's sent to
the proxy and then back and forth and
actually a guy called Jimmy song has
created this really useful blog post
about this again I'm not going to go
through the
diagram here but you can see the
traffic's coming in from the left it's
going into pre routing it's sent to East
your inbound and then it's kind of sent
to the proxy back in force of the proxy
can do its thing and then it's it
towards the end it's sent into the app
container and then from the app
container when it goes out it also goes
through the proxy due to this routing
and then the proxy can add all kinds of
stuff to it and or the policy evaluation
and things like that and then we
actually send the traffic out so if you
want to learn more about it go read this
blog post and at least look at this
diagram in more detail because really
useful one of the things I was wondering
about with this was how can a if we
redirect the traffic using IP tables and
we were gonna we have an outbound
connection it's going to google.com and
then we have something that hijacks it
and sends it on to another service how
can this service that gets it know where
it was supposed to go and it turns out
that there's a way to get socket options
in C and I am NOT a C programmer so I
didn't know this area originally but in
if we redirect this using IP tables we
can ask the socket but what was your
original destination so that's what's
the second line here and we can do this
from even from from JavaScript or other
languages we just have to find the right
api's for it but that's how it knows
what was the original did the proxy
knows what was the original location of
this because there's no normal proxy
headers that we would have an HTTP where
we're like saying well connected to this
thing and server etc it's all it's all
on the on the socket low so a side note
on this net admin capability is that
this is the thing that's had a lot of
bugs around it and some CDs so it's not
something you want you to let your
containers have while it's running
so they made a really sane choice and
this in this architecture that they use
it only in the init container and let
that set up the traffic so it goes
through the proxy and then it's dropped
so you don't have that capability in the
containers anymore that's not something
you want out there's a really good paper
from NCC group called understanding and
hardening Linux containers which I
highly recommend you read if your
interests
in doctor and container security routing
in policies we can do a lot of things
with sto around routing and and policies
so we can do automatic load balancing
for many different types of traffic we
can do a fine-grained control so we can
we can do things like a circuit breakers
and retries so we can say well if you
try to connect this thing and it's not
answering well wait a bit and then try
again or we can failover to different
services if one of them is failing we
can also do things like policies and
this can be interesting in terms of
denial of service for instance if if one
of our services is really hammering and
one of the others it might be useful to
introduce rate limits or or quote us and
we can also do access control using is
do the communication itself is set up
using mutual TLS or at least we can set
it up to use mutual TLS and we can use
this as a way to get authentication and
authorization but before we we go into
detail on how that works we're going to
sidetrack a little bit and talk about
something called spiffy spiffy is the
secure production identity framework for
everyone it's on spiffy i/o and it's
inspired by googling Google create it's
called a LTS application layer Transport
Security one of the ideas here is when
we're starting deploying containers and
all kinds of of application micro
services we we don't really care that
much about the hostname anymore because
these things will move around they won't
stay at one host they're gonna move
around from different notes to all kinds
of places and so using hostname as the
identity of a let's say us or
certificate that doesn't make much sense
anymore what we want to know is the
workloads so we want to know am i
speaking to the right type of process am
i speaking to right type of micro
service I don't really care where it is
as long as it has this way of proving
that it is the workload that it's
supposed to be so we have
we work load or service identification
instead of host identification in in
spiffy we have a kind of Uri buy based
scheme which is called a spiffy ID and
the spiffy ID has an issuer as the first
part and then we have some kind of
identifier on the right side this
doesn't have to be hierarchical it can
be but it doesn't have to be but we have
the issuer of the of this ID and then we
have some kind of some kind of
identifier for the service itself to
prove your spiffy identity we have a
spiffy verifiable identity document and
this contains two spiffy ID it contains
a public key and it contains a valid
signature so this is of course normally
implemented as x.509 certificates and
this is what what is do is using as well
usually these things are short-lived as
well we want them to be shortly we want
to issue new certificate often and then
just remove the other ones and the one
and have them expire as fast as possible
basically so if we're going to use Biffy
we can use something called spire the
spiffy runtime environment and in this
case we set up a spire server over here
and we have a node agent that runs on a
node and the node agent will first have
to register it with the spire server so
it sits there and what the node agent
does it does at the station so when we
fire up some kind of a service on this
node this the node agent knows something
about this service it can be if you know
what what container hash it has it can
know what kind of a process it is it can
do all kinds of at the stations to
figure out what is this service that's
now trying to be a part of this networks
so the service will just simply ask the
node agent who am i and the node agent
will then go to the spire server to get
some kind of credential for this and
then from there on on the service can
use this credential to speak to other
services so why am I talking about
spiffy
well Sto off the authorization and
authentication part is is or at least
the authentication part is it's
considered a spiffy implementation the
spiffy people are reopen saying
i sto is one of the implementations of
spiffy while the sto people are more in
terms of well su has a spiffy
implementation but it also offers a lot
more what it does in this case instead
of having this spire server that's a
very different thing in these node
agents so we're using the underlying
platform which is kubernetes and we're
using that for at the station so that
the platform itself knows which pods are
running where and we can use this to
give them certificates but so it's the
office is more comprehensive inspired
because it doesn't just do
authentication but it also does
authorization and auditing and all kinds
of metrics and things like that so we
can get from from history and here we
come back to this SEO Citadel because
this Citadel was something formerly
known as sto CA because it's it's kind
of a certificate authority it creates
the certificate creates this these SV
documents for us
and it actually runs as a kubernetes pod
itself so I can show you quickly just
what happens if we list out what's
running in our and what's going to
happen when you install this do which is
quite easy is you're going to get a new
namespace called
sto system and within this Istria system
namespace there's gonna be a set of pods
running so we can do this we're gonna
see the pods is running so we see the
Citadel as the second one up here we see
the egress and ingress gateways and we
see the pilot and some other things as
well in here so this the this Citadel it
runs as a Cuban era spot in sits in
years to an atheist but it has some
rights into all namespaces in the system
it has a CA certificate if you don't
provide one to it it's going to create
one a self signed one but you can if you
have an existing PKI you can for
instance you can issue on intermediate
CA and you can plug that in and have it
use that one instead
so the citadel has rights to all the
namespaces on your cluster because it
needs to be able to create secrets
though Secrets is where it stores these
these certificates and it needs to be
able to watch these secrets and to see
what's happening through them so and it
also looks for service accounts and
services which we'll get back to so the
these SV documents in Israel they're
created by this Citadel it's per service
account so it's not really tied to the
workload as such but as long as we run
each pod with or if not each pod but
each deployment with the specific with
unique service account this works as
intended the default is that these
certificates are valid for one hour so
they're really short-lived certificates
I mean we're used to having certificates
that are valid for a year or two but now
we have certificates that are valid for
only one hour so if someone steals one
of these it's it's quickly going to
expire
they're also refreshed every 30 minutes
so you won't have these delays where you
try to renew something and you're too
late and then you're going to get an
outage so there we have a 30 minute gap
these are these things are all
configurable so you can you can set them
up with with different time limits if
you want to so the certificate only
contains the spiffy spiffy ID there's
there are no dns names in these
certificates and this can sometimes be
annoying if you're trying to do like a
cluster where you have some things using
Sto and some things that are not using
is do typically a job application will
have problems or talking to one of this
Buffay things because it's going to it's
going to hit a certificate that doesn't
have a dns name and it's gonna not going
to be trusted by default as mentioned
these this certificate are also tied to
the service account so you can if you
want to you can boot up multiple
workloads that are very different with
the same service account and thus they
will get the same certificate an
interesting thing that I noticed when I
had worked on this for a while trying to
look at what it's doing we installed it
and we were using it a bit is a bug that
was introduced in 0.51 this is the
commit that fixes the problem
but the problem in this case was that
they introduced a grace period as a
conflict setting so you could say how
long before the certificate expires are
you supposed to renew it but the problem
was in this case that they were using
integers and they weren't aware that
they were using integers so in this case
we ended up with if you set the grace
period to 0.5 it would become 0 and so
the certificates would not be renewed
until after they had expired which is
kind of annoying so you get like a 1
minute gap at once per hour where
everything would fail and like what's
going on why is it failing and I was
reading through the code and actually
found this thing and and then I went
back in and so well they've actually
fixed it in a newer version and I
wouldn't have had to spend all this time
reading code to figure out what was
going on but the weird thing was that
this was in 0.5 which at the point was
supposed to be like a long-term release
at least for awhile but they fixed it in
a short-term release which was 0.6 and I
tried to make them fix it back in 0.5
but they and they didn't want to but
this is fixed now of course so we were
using mutual TLS between these services
or these pods and so we were creating
these TLS channels so we this doesn't
have to be HTTP I mean it doesn't have
to be HTTP it can be any type of TCP
connection and we can enforce this on
either a cluster level so we can say
that all the pods that I have in my
cluster now there are going to use
mutual TLS between them or we can say
that only the pods with in this specific
namespace they are going to use mutual
TLS but the other ones I don't care
about or you can also do it on on a
service level so this is the this is
kind of the way that we set this up
we're using these rules so in this case
we're saying
TLS mode is two mutual and if you're
going to speak to something that started
local you have to use this and there
there you can see that you arrive down
at the bottom here on on the sto
document pages there are a lot of tasks
that you can do to learn how this works
which is really useful this is the way
that you used to do authorization by
in sto 0.5 and this was kind of horrible
the first time I looked at it to be
honest because this is a blacklist
approach so we have Adonai product
Handler denier and and we were saying
like well this spiffy ID here is not
allowed to talk to us and of course this
is not the way we want to do security we
want to say who's allowed to talk to us
not who is not allowed to talk to us
because that's that would be really hard
to get right and luckily they fix this
in in later versions so we now have a
much wider way of awfully doing
authorization as well so in this case we
have a couple of rules with any services
that start with tests anyone can call
them but if there's a service called
bookstore default as we see it goes
local and you're trying to go to the
reviews paths and using get there you
can add two constraints so we can do
kind of fine-grained authorization here
I'm not sure that I think this is a good
idea I would rather use like an
authorization that says you're allowed
to speak to the service or not and put
the actual authorization in the
application itself but it's possible at
least here is another here is how we
bind this we created the service role
and then we can bind this role to a
service account so in the previous
version we have everything in one but
now in the latest version of this do we
have two different so we created us a
row and then we bind the role to a
service account so and we allow them to
to talk we can also do something like
this so we have this properties request
auth claims email okay what's this all
about well actually sto doesn't just add
service to service mutual TLS but it
also adds a way to do end-user
validation so this is implemented it for
now it supports JSON web tokens jots and
we can have sto check the signature of
these tokens on their way in instead of
having to do it ourselves in the
applications and it it supports what
zero firebase Google auth but you can
also do your own if you want to
and it's quite it's actually quite easy
to set up so in this case we have a
service and what we configure it to do
is we can say this is where you find my
my JSON web keys or in this location
here and if you ever see a token coming
in with an issuer called demo you're
gonna use this disc the key the public
keys that you find on this location to
try to verify it so I have an example of
that as well so in this case I have a
service that's deployed on my cluster
and if I try to invoke it I get a 401
unauthorized as you can see up here if I
look at what's what's actually deployed
in this cluster its I have added a
policy and the important parts are what
you see down here this is the like the
demo in key store and the demo is sure
that that's used if you do the tasks for
a phrase do that's in the documentation
so I have to have a token and luckily I
have a talk you know as well so I can
try to call this with the token it
should be here and actually it's failing
right now that's fun always fun probably
it might be because I'm now I'm not
connected to the internet and it can't
download the JSON web pieces it's gonna
fail normally what would happen is it
would it would add the original it will
forward the original token in the header
to the end target service yeah
so the sto authorization is
coarse-grained it's on you can do like
path based authorization you can do
source based authorization but I'm not
really sure that this is where I want to
add those kinds of things I'm I'm um
I've seen these things go wrong many
times so I'm not sure that that's what I
want to do and and and there's also
something other than some other thing
that's a bit annoying at the moment and
that's issue it doesn't forward this
beefy identity to the container
as such the the authorization stops in
the in the proxy so the application
itself has no way of knowing which
service was calling it so if this was
like let's say this was a search index
or something and you wanted to have
different search indexes for different
micro services there's no way for the
pot itself to know which service is now
calling in which data to provide I added
this as an issue in in the github repo
but that issue repo has now been renamed
to old issues repo because then I moved
all the issues to a new repo but it
didn't move mine but then someone else
actually added a new issue on the new
rep repo and they're now considering
adding this in 1.1 so you can actually
get the spiffy ID all the way into the
application and know who the callers are
you can also use these sto certs without
the sidecar so you don't have to use the
proxy and this this can actually be a
bit useful if if you let's say you you
at the moment you want to be able to
know which certificates are coming in or
which clients are calling you but you
don't want to use the proxy because you
want to have the certificates all the
way into your application what you could
do it is you could set up an engine X
for instance and you can use that to to
verify the certificates and then forward
the identities into your applications so
because these certificates they're just
Cuba NetID secrets which also means that
they're just stored as base64 encoded
stuff in the cluster but yeah you can
you can you can use them you can mount
them into your own applications so what
I usually do is my when I've done this
is unmounted Emma's volumes into the
containers
and then actually what kubernetes will
do is it whenever the secret changes it
will update the volume that's mounted
into the application this is contrary to
popular belief that like when you start
a container if whatever changes you do
to the sequence it's not going to be
reflected then you have to restart the
containers but secrets are actually
updated and I have a demo of this as
well because we can set up an
application that's like kind of
listening for filesystem events and then
reloads their certificates so in in
node.js we can simply do something like
this I've mounted the certificates under
a slash secret and then I can do FS
watch watch for changes and whenever
there's a change I'm gonna notify the
clients so I have this tiny little
website here which has a it now has a
certificate that's loaded you don't
really have to read what's up there just
says there is a certificate and it was
loaded and I'm now going to go in and
show you what we can do with this
because we now have these secrets here
and you can see the sto secrets are
called
sto dot and then the name of the service
account and the type is sto dot io key
insert so we didn't it such a secret we
have the private key we have the public
key and we have the CA chain so we can
mount this in but what happens if we
delete one of them so now I'm going to
delete the one called SPO website up
there and what I'm doing up here with
the dot with the dash W is I'm watching
what are the what secrets are there so
immediately when I delete this it's
gonna say a something something went
missing and then it's gonna actually
create a new one so if I delete a secret
I can do this many times if I delete
it's just gonna immediately create a new
one from for me and this is this is the
watching part this is what all the
rights that the the Citadel has where
it's kind of watching all kinds of stuff
watching all the secrets throughout the
cluster this is what it's using so it's
it's also watching these things if I now
go back to this this website you can see
it's now updated because II it got only
the filesystem events that says hey this
secret is updated
you now have a new certificate so we now
got a new certificate with a new expiry
because I just killed the old one and it
immediately adds a new one
so this isn't this is quite easy to just
listen on filesystem event no when the
certificate is updated and then changed
to using that I'm my worries about using
SEO and and a service mesh of any other
kind is miss configuration so let's say
we're setting this up we're adding all
kinds of applications to to our
kubernetes cluster and then we messed
something up with the configuration and
if we now trusted all authorization
authentication and everything else to
these to sto and history was not working
properly well all the security is
basically borked also I'm a bit worried
about broken access control because I
I'm wondering if we're gonna see cases
where things are not handled the same
way in the proxy as in the application
itself we can have some kind of
impedance mismatch between how they do
URL parsing for instance so maybe it's
GOC something is to say well this is
okay but then when it comes into the
application it does a double decode or
something and then it kind of fails
regardless so there are some things to
look for there also is tio bugs like we
had the the timing bugs but there's
there's been some other bugs as well so
what I would do is I would use some kind
of tests and kind of automate automated
verification tests that checks whether
or not you have access and things like
that
assign odom bugs in when sto was zero
point our 1.0 the two was released in
September 2018 one of the things that I
wanted to fix was a bug in envoy where
the sidecar would crash if receiving
normal traffic on the mutual TLS port
that's kind of a nasty bug and we just
killed the proxy immediately if you try
to send non TLS traffic so there there
have been quite a few bugs there was a
big blog post couple of months ago also
where someone was writing about all the
problems that they had we just do and
it's it is still quite new so but I it
looks like there's a lot of power behind
it so and I think it's going to be quite
good
actually and it's getting there now
because they're doing a lot of work on
it all the time
another question that I've gotten is
like are our service meshes the new app
servers and what what I mean by there or
what what the person meant by that this
was for those of you who have been
developing job applications on App
servers you know that we we we took out
a lot of the stuff that was in the
application and we put them in the app
server so the app servers they would do
authentication and authorization and
they would do database connection
pooling and they would do all kinds of
stuff
and this is kind of in the direction
where is do is or is do some of these
things as well it kind of pulls things
out of the application and to kind of
understand why this is a problem
consider as a thing such as a service
breakers with retries like how would you
know if it's ok to retry this thing is
if it failed that's probably something
the application itself knows better than
the service mesh-like is it okay to try
to transfer this amount of money more
than once if it fails the first time
maybe not maybe you don't want to do
that so like use a bit of caution when
you're when you're using something like
this that's that's basically what I'm
trying to say here
so to summarize all of this sto provides
quite a lot of things most importantly
security wise is this service to service
authentication through mutual TLS and
this allows us to to have encrypted
channels so if we go all the way back to
the threats that we looked at at the
beginning we now have even if this
attacker is able to breach one of our
containers that doesn't necessarily mean
that that attacker is able to attack
other containers the attacker would
still be able to try to breach out of
the container if the if the platform
itself had vulnerabilities but at least
we've now we've used this to try to
protect the services that we have from
each other we can can have end-user
authentication through JWT I'm guessing
that they might want to add other types
of end user authentication as well we
can actually choose where we want to do
the
JWT evaluation as well we can do it
either on the ingress so all the way to
the front where when the request is
coming into the cluster or we can do it
at the proxy level itself when I try to
do this recently while preparing this
talk it's failed when I try to do it in
the proxy I can do it in the ingress but
I can't do it in the proxy I would just
get out of 503 service unavailable all
the time if I try to do it and in the
proxy itself so it had to be on the
ingress for now I'm not sure what's
going on there was a big discussion on
github about this as well why it wasn't
working it might be because the cluster
I'm using is mini cube which is like a 1
DM given a DS cluster and it's not quite
the same as running in a proper
kubernetes cluster we as mentioned we
can do authorization through policies so
we we use policies to set up who can
talk to who and if they need to use
mutual TLS and all kinds of stuff and we
can of course you do the rate-limiting
and the other things as well
with Google being one of the the
companies behind this do it's really
easy to set this up if you're using
containers on kubernetes on a Google
cloud because they've done a lot of work
to make it easy to deploy but it's also
quite easy to deploy on a normal machine
as well like on for instance on mini
cube because what you get when you
download the code is is a set of of
deployment files so let's see here so I
downloaded version 1.0 dot 5 here and
have the old one dot zero dot one as
well and in inherit is an install folder
and we can choose where we want to
install it so we can say ok this is
Cuban Alice or it's googled out and
there are some some of the llamo files
that we can use to install it
there is also an idea about you being
able to use sto outside of kubernetes so
you can have some workloads that exists
on other types of hosts like in just
like a normal
occasional running in a VM or something
like that that could also be a part of
the service mesh because the service
mesh can be extended outside of
kubernetes went through the mechanisms
that they've added which is also quite
interesting because then we we're not no
longer limited to to only using this in
incriminates there are some resources if
you want to learn more about this the
first part here is the security
documentation under Doc's concept
security
there's the documentation for sto is
super good I'm really impressed with
what they've done and especially these
tasks that they have where you cannot
just do security related tasks but you
can do all kinds of tasks related to Sto
so you can do you you get a set of
applications that you can deploy and
then you can set up these kind of
circuit breakers and fault injection and
all kinds of things through these tasks
so this is a really good way to learn it
if you want to try it out there's also
really good talk called sto
defense-in-depth from modern production
environment from cloud next last year
which I also recommend that you take a
look at if you find this to be
interesting but yeah the documentation
is super good so you can learn a lot of
the stuff that you can do it with ease
just by reading the documentation may be
setting up mini cube yourself the way I
did and just install it stay on that or
or using Google Cloud for that matter
and set it up there instead so I tried
to find a picture to explain what a pot
is and this thing came up as a pods
works together lights music and sounds
bounce back and forth so this is the
sidecar on one side and the service on
the sorry
that's it any questions at all
yes
[Music]
so trying to rephrase kubernetes has a
lot of complexity is too adds more
complexity and a lot of companies are
concerned with this complexity when when
will sto be production ready that's a
good question I know there are some
companies that are now using in the in
production
I think knob here in Oslo is using it in
production at least to some degree
there has been some issues with it they
have some issues with like health checks
in kubernetes as far as I understood
from them so but this is something
that's being worked on all the time and
there's there seems to be quite a big a
lot of commits coming into to the github
repo and iGoogle and and with Google and
these other companies being behind it I
think we're we're kind of approaching in
a setting with that said I would never
run my own kubernetes cluster like try
to set up a burn areas or nodes because
that's super complex tasks so I would
probably use this on on my cloud
providers urban area set ups like Google
cloud or maybe usher or or Amazon any
other questions
do okay thanks for listening
[Applause]